hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we're going to cover from the
quarterfinals of the earthings masters
2022 uh the preliminaries are over and
now it's time to see who will advance to
the semi-finals and uh here uh it's the
third game of the match andrey sipenko
versus eric hansen the first two games
ended in the draw however the third one
might not have uh and it's just a
spectacular game in its entirety you
guys will see what i mean so uh let's
dive straight into it spinker with the
white pieces opens with e4 uh we have e5
by eric knight to f3 knights to c6 and
bishop to b5 is panko goes for the rui
lopez and eric goes for the berlin
defense we have knight to f6 uh d3 and
now bishop to c5 so no funny business uh
droish lines uh we have bishop captures
on c6 d captures and now uh is pink or
just castle's king side we have knight
to d7 now we often mentioned that
you have to defend the e5 pawn somehow
some popular moves are queen to e79
bishop g for even bishop d6 uh here we
have bishop knight back to d7 uh by eric
and c3 now preparing to go for the early
uh central push with the d4
we have castles by eric and now d4 uh we
have bishop to d6 so this is all very
standard stuff nothing new here uh
bishop to g5 attacking the black queen
and now f6 this is the most popular idea
here uh bishop back to h4 and now queen
to e8 so again still all uh theory of
the berlin we have knight beat to d2 and
now comes something very very nice so
here known ideas are queen to something
like queen to e7 also knight to b6 is
known uh and alireza ferruga had this
position against dmitry and draken under
again tried queen to e6 here alireza i
was able to win that game but here eric
plays b5 and it is now as of movie 11
that we have a completely new game so
let's see uh how is panko deals with
this
new development so here uh he of course
uh
advances the pawn to a4 he wants to
trade here and open up the a file for
his rook king the h8 by eric getting the
king off of this diagonal as you will
constantly have to worry about this and
now rook to e1 just nicely continuing
development we have a5 now
and bishop to g3 we have knight to b6
and here we have b3 and finally a trade
on a4 so b captures on a4 b captures and
now uh c5 so this is how eric plans to
destroy white center and it's a very
nice trick actually if uh if white
decides to close the center with the d5
then c4 and it's uh well good luck
playing this with white there's a
there's no good plan here for white
black will play bishop to a6 that pawn
on c4 is uh cemented and it's just gonna
be all black this game so instead we
have d characters on e5 uh we have f
captures on e5 and i semi open a file
for that rook and now c4 uh spingo does
not allow eric to execute the c4 move uh
knight to d7 and uh here with white
playing c4 is where the fun really
starts because by playing c4 uh yes you
gain extra control over the d5 square
but you lose control over the d4 square
and this is where eric starts
re-maneuvering the knight so now he
wants to play knight
at the seven knight b knights to c6 and
knight to d4 as this is now a beautiful
square for this knight so he starts with
knight to d7 now comes knight to f1 uh
we have knight to b8 going for that d4
square queen to d5 now absolutely the
best move by
spankle going for for the rook on e8 and
it's also a trick if you play knights
the c6 now which is kind of what you
were going for the problem is there's
knight captures on e5 and you're just
losing a pawn because the knight can
capture the rook would hang so you would
have to trade everything here bishop
characters bishop captures an e5 and
after queen captures you're going to
capture on c6 uh just winning a pawn so
after uh this queen to d5 eric plays a
rook to a7 he gets the rook out of
harm's way and now still bishop captures
on e5 uh it seems like you're winning a
pawn but not really because bishop to b7
attacking the queen and this is the
moment where the magic happens uh spanko
doesn't move the queen uh in fact he
sacrifices the queen here plays bishop
captures on d6 and it's uh now that you
see it it it makes perfect sense of
course we're going after the rook and f8
and if
the bishop captures queen we can even
play some like c captures on d5 uh get
nice nicely connected two pawns in the
center maybe start pushing our e pawn so
it's all uh you know it's all there but
still making such a decision
very quickly in a rapid game
uh definitely is is something else so
there's nothing but to capture the queen
bishop captures and e5 was played and
now bishop captures an f8 and this is
that
one moment
after a sacrifice has been made where
you really have to recollect yourself
and just play bishop captures on c4 it's
easier said than done of course but it's
often in your own games when your
opponent sacrifices something uh then
usually you have a few moves where you
can really uh you know consolidate and
[Music]
make the position harmless uh but that's
uh always easier said than done so here
what you would have to do is bishop
captures on c4 and then okay white also
gets the bishop back bishop captures and
c5 attacks the rook rugby seven and the
game continues however here eric played
queen capture son of fate and now is
panko gets the two past pawns in the
center c captures on the e5 and it's
still not lost for black but it's much
much harder to play against this so eric
plays a c6
making it
impossible for white to keep the two
connected pass pawns uh
okay now this one could become a pass
pawn it's still not however it's
impossible to push the middle so you can
now bring the rook anywhere along the
the seventh rank so knight the e3 are
getting ready for the capture here and
here eric plays h6 which takes away the
g5 square from the knight but it weakens
the g6 square and uh of course his
pencil goes after that g6 square so
knight to e5 going after knight to g6
this would be a very nice royal fork
king the h7 guarding the g6 square and
now knight three to d4 uh really just
improving your position so c captures on
d5 this has to be captured at some point
e captures and denied knight to d7
offering a trade and this trade is good
for both white and black so nothing
wrong with that so knight captures on d7
rook captures on d7 and now d6 and this
is the position that really uh
fascinates me uh
after d6
queen to f4 going after the knight and
now just rook a to c1 and now if you
look at this this is the position i
decided to
show in the thumbnail uh okay black has
a queen however white has a knight and a
rook for the queen but even that
doesn't really matter all that much uh
because uh well sorry about that uh the
knight uh guards the pawn here the rook
guards the knight and this rook regards
this rook so what can black even try to
do here everything is so nicely defended
that it seems like um you you can only
wait for the for the inevitable uh so
here uh
after this rook a to c one we have rook
to b7 and it's uh immediately a mistake
uh what you have to do here is play rook
to f7 this is your one uh counter play
that you have
and you do not want to pass out uh an
opportunity to play it for example rook
to f1 defends the f2 pawn now we play
rook to f5 something like this we go
maybe after rook to d5 but still it's
very difficult after knight e3 attacking
the rook uh the the pass spawn is now
ready to march forward you're gonna lose
the c5 pawn so it's uh it's very
difficult to play but it is playable uh
however after this rook the b7 move
instead of rook to f7 uh there's no
threat uh we would look to b7 and now
isipenko plays g3 uh he attacks the
queen and also creates some very
important breeding room for the for the
white q for the white king uh also
instead of g3 knights the e5 uh taking
advantage of uh black not creating any
threats right away is incredibly strong
because now d7 is coming uh but okay g3
attacks the queen we have queen to f5
and then now we have rook e to d1
improving the position even further now
you have a rook behind the pass pawn and
is there any counter play for black so
rook to d7 can be played but it's such a
sad move to make you know that if you
make this you will only be waiting for
something to happen so here eric starts
pushing h5 yes panko prevents this with
h4 uh and now rook to a7
uh waiting uh well waiting to see what
happens knight to e3 attacks the queen
queen to d7 and it's always sad when you
have to use your queen as a blockading
piece rook captures on c5 now going
after the h5 pawn but there doesn't seem
to be
anything black can do about his rook the
queen captures on a4 creating a pass
pawn of his own
rook captures an h5 with czech king to
g8 and now rook h back to d5 now both of
the rooks are ready to push the pawn so
you absolutely have to blockade this
rook to d7 was played now rook five to
d4
attacking the queen queen to b5 and now
knight to d5 going for this uh a very
nice advancement of the knight because
if the pawn is captured of course we
just deliver a check and pick up the
rook here or rather the exchange so
instead after 95 king the h7 getting out
of the range of the knight now comes
knight to c7 attacks the queen queen to
b3 and now rook to d5 uh going after the
pawn here so eric starts advancing it
and now knight to e6 uh and okay what
can you do here uh well you could
continue with something like a3 but the
knight of fate check and then you lose
the uh lose the rook so you have to do
something about this eric brings the
queen back queen to b8 to guard the f8
square now comes knight to c5 again
attacking the rook and the thing is if
you move the rook now then d7 is
incredibly strong the 8 is coming you
can't really do anything about this so
rook to d8 was played but this is again
inevitable knight captures on a4 is
played queen to a7 attacking the knight
maybe trying to now uh with some uh
last resort moves so go go after the f2
pawn maybe knight to c5 and now queen to
f7 we have d7 uh rook to f8 in the now
comes rook one to d2 just adding a
defender to the f2 pawn and he was in
this position on move 48 that eric
hansen resigned the game uh as there is
nothing more to be done here of course
uh once we play rook to d8 where we can
play pretty much anything the position
is completely winning for white but even
the simple knight b7 just going after
the rook wins and that's it uh we either
captured the rook and then well
let's say black plays a move king to h6
we can simply capture here
of course giving up the rook and if you
try defending the rook we still just
capture and then play whatever rook to
e2 the d7 point is defender we play rook
t8 so there there's uh
an infinite number of ways that you can
win this there are also ways you can
lose this still but
chances are you would win this uh so
yeah very very nice victory for uh for
you yes pencil in round three of the
quarter finals i'm not going to spoil
any results from the other matches as
i'm going to show at least one more game
from
one of the matches uh and then we're
going to discuss what happened and uh
who is advancing to the semi-final so we
do not have two days of the
quarterfinals only one day and uh next
day is already the semi-finals uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really uh a beautiful
position for espnko eric had that one
opportunity to
uh you know uh not not allow all of this
but it's always like that when one
player sacrifices the queen you're very
low on time it doesn't have to be the
queen it can be anything else
you know
if you don't find it then you will be
suffering for a very long time but here
after this rook a to c one this is the
position i enjoyed the most everything
is defended and you know it's just gonna
be a slow slow and painful death for
black and you know any inevitable one
uh so once again hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank ivan
sterling pp poopoo uh richard schwartz
ryan urban and cloud strive for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
quarterfinals uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day